it's a simple question that now
terrifies politicians the world over and
it's this what is a woman what's a woman
but what is a woman what is a woman out
of interest can a woman have a penis
facts or facts science is science
uh can you answer for me this very
simple question what is a woman
of course i can't answer the question
anyway a woman is a female and the
female is defined by the genes she has
essentially she has two x chromosomes as
she's human normally and that would be
that would be the
definitive it's probably easier to
define a male a male has specific
masculine genes which make us different
from women and the the female position
is the default human position that that
is to say if there's no male genes there
you're born as a woman
but i mean dictionaries just simply say
a woman is an adult female and a man is
an adult male
why is the world finding it all so
complicated now
it is really quite extraordinary
basically we are a cluster standing here
i'm a clump of about eight trillion
cells at least each of which of those
cells has got my maleness in it i'm
defined genetically every single cell
has got those male genes and that would
apply to a woman who doesn't have those
genes so that makes a difference and we
cannot escape the fact that we are
genetically determined in this way of
course they define in terms of shape for
example where they have breasts and all
the rest of it but essentially that's
what it amounts to what is a woman to
you so for me a woman is someone who is
an adult who is human and is female and
female is both a biological category
where we talk about biological sex and a
gender category so depending on what
we're talking about if you're saying
best female rapper no one's checking
chromosomes if you're talking about
female reproductive health you know
people aren't just talking about your
social life um it can be a biological or
a gender so when for example the hot
issue of the day when you have trans
women athletes
who are competing against women born to
female biological bodies do you think
that's fair do i think that's fair i
think you'd have to take a look at the
whole picture
leah thomas the swimmer so it might be
that in five to ten years when you have
much more
uh trans athletes breaking through and
you might see
cisgender women at a disadvantage you
have to go let's read let's rejig the
system in a way which can protect
women's sport and include trans people i
think right now because trans people
have been so marginalized so here's my
problem you're a smart young lady right
i follow you on twitter you're very
smart you you're very intellectually
rigorous about stuff
you know you know when you look at stuff
like leah thomas demolishing women in
the pool in america that this isn't fair
and you can support as i do and you do
trans rights defenders and equality and
understand that on issues like sport it
is unfair what is a woman
what what i got to do with the price of
friends piers i literally told you i'm
about to debate
what is a woman what do you mean ask an
expert i said ask the next girl do you
know what a woman is a woman is someone
who defines as a woman period done
anyone next guest anyone okay i'm a
woman is that yeah i said next guest
because that's not my second if i if i
said my work i know you're trying to
trap me and i'm not falling if i say i'm
like
do you agree i'm a woman i said
next guest because i'm not falling for
it bye you're not getting your little
clip out of me your little audio
without realizing it you may have just
given me my little clip that's the point
that's wonderful that ironically is the
clip that's wonderful because when young
women can't actually say what a woman is
i think it's mad i'm a woman
i'm a young woman who's very proud
who exercise their democratic right to
protest and do so in a way that is in
line with the law what is a woman me
[Laughter]
senior without her over there
there's plenty of us
but are you worried that in this trans
debate because i support trans rights
defenders so do i of course i just don't
like the attack on women's rights that
some of the activists are driving where
you have in sport this apparent
unfairness now going what do you think
when you see that
well i don't watch sport no but you know
what i'm talking about well i know what
you're talking about yes and i know what
you want me to say i don't need to say
anything
no no i don't this is uncensored um
well of course it's uncensored i think
that a person should be
who they feel that they are
and who they
but i do believe
i can't say this i can't
no i can't why you feel like you've got
because you make it i can't because i
don't want to get hate now you see but
you've gone through your entire career
saying exactly what you always think no
i haven't yes you have no i've read your
daughter
i've never i've never gotten into the
politics of biology okay no i haven't i
understand why people don't want to go
there yes i don't want to go there if i
asked you what a woman is what would you
say
let's say a a human being with uh boobs
how are you to start there yeah i mean
the dictionary is quite straightforward
it just seems like an adult female right
now a lot of people yeah see that's now
that's a little getting confusing the
whole
day that's good that's good and i'm not
sure why really it's a bit like this
whole issue of transgenders in sport
because i can i support all trans rights
to fairness and equality
but not where you have people born to
obvious physical superior bodies
transitioning and then thrashing the
women at their sport i totally agree and
i i will say this and everybody's gonna
hate me but as a woman
just because you go change your parts
doesn't make you a woman right sorry
you feel that
i know that for a fact like if you want
me to call you her i will because that's
what you want but that doesn't make you
a woman just cause i call you or her and
just because you got a surgery a woman
is an adult female who does not have a
penis i can't even believe i have to say
that on air
this is not something that should be
debated it's a biological fact you can't
refute basic scientific sexual
physiology how we got here matt how we
got to a place
where young women
are paralyzed with fear about even
saying what they are
this is a gender ideology i mean that's
why that's what this is and uh
uh you know you can kind of if you want
to trace it back you could kind of
decide how far back you want to go there
are certain landmark moments you can
point to in history now i think for a
lot of people it feels like
everyone knew what a woman was and a man
was a man a woman was a woman up until
about
eight years ago and then everyone lost
their minds
final question ma in the interest of
fair play what is a man
well if a woman is an adult human female
then i suppose a man would be an adult
human male i would say i think it really
is as simple as that
you